For more than two weeks now, the sun has burned down on Japan...
...from a cloudless sky with barely a waft of wind.
Outside the Imperial Palace in Tokyo, the heat shimmer tells its own story.
Here, the tourists are sweltering in only 37 degrees today.
A little further north, in the city of Kumagaya, it is considerably hotter.
The thermometer here hit 41.1 degrees on Monday,...
...the highest ever recorded anywhere in Japan.
The heat is not just uncomfortable, it is now extremely dangerous.
At Tokyo's Emergency Dispatch Center, the calls are coming thick and fast.
The ambulance crews are struggling to keep up...
...as across Japan, more than 30,000 people have now been hospitalized...
...with heatstroke or heat exhaustion.
The elderly are most at risk.
More than half of the deaths reported so far have been people over 65.
In the ancient capital, Kyoto, the summer festivals are underway.
Here, it has been 38 degrees or more for a solid week, another record.
All of this is being caused by a huge high pressure dome...
...that is sitting over the top of Japan and Korea.
For the last two weeks, it has refused to budge.
The bad news: it could be here for another two.